[Music]
Hibbert's Boris Johnson's first
parliamentary voters British prime
minister and he lost it to the 328 the
nose to the left 301 to the eyes of it
the eyes have it
Johnson was hit by a huge rebellion
among his own Conservative MPs 21 of
them joined the opposition to seize the
brexit agenda costing Johnson his
working majority they're trying to pass
a law that would delay the UK's exit
from the EU and prevent an ideal brakes
it
Johnson insists Deal or No Deal brexit
will happen on October the 31st he says
he has no option now but to call for an
early general election tomorrow to stop
negotiations had to compel another
pointless delay to brexit potentially
for years that would be the only way to
resolve this but johnson could struggle
to get a two-thirds majority needed to
approve an early poll opposition leader
Jeremy Corbyn has long called for
elections but now says he won't agree to
them until the anti No Deal bill passes
there is no consent in this house to
leave the European Union without a deal
there is no majority for no deal in the
car
on Wednesday the cross-party Alliance
will introduce their bill to delay
breaks it with October 31 just over
eight weeks away all the turmoil and
political maneuvering is only stoking
more confusion about how and when brexit
will happen well for the very latest
let's cross over to our correspondent
Charlotte Potts in London and our
correspondent max Hoffman is standing by
for us in Brussels let's start with you
Charlotte high drama in the British
Parliament where does it go from here
starting with today well we've witnessed
quite an extraordinary showdown
yesterday there in Parliament after
Boris Johnson essentially lost that vote
and Parliament seized the order paper he
kicked out 21 members and out of his
Conservative Party so those rebels that
voted against him so Boris Johnson in
Parliament has definitely lost his
majority and we're expecting that
showdown to continue today in Parliament
we are expecting later this afternoon a
vote on whether to force Boris Johnson's
hand whether to force him to ask the
European Union for yet another extension
this time until January 31st this is
what this bill is about it has to be
approved first of all by Parliament and
then also by the House of Lords so this
will drag on in the course of the week
and if that vote is successful Boris
Johnson has already said he is calling
for another election for a general
election he believes he has lost the
leverage to negotiate with the European
Union to find another deal and therefore
he is seeking another mandate a mandate
this time around to really see his
breakthrough and for the UK to leave the
European Union by October 31st so we
might see a general election here in the
UK coming up very soon max a fluid
situation there in London a crumbling
government what to these developments
mean for the EU and its preparations for
brexit urologists said that Boris
Johnson believes he might lose his
leverage with the EU I think the
is here in Brussels is he never le never
had any leverage but believe it or not
his chief brexit and boy David Frost is
in town to officially negotiate things
like the backstop very contentious that
is the insurance policy against a hard
border between northern island which is
part of the UK and the Republic of
Ireland which is part of the European
Union and you remember when Boris
Johnson said they're making good
progress and a deal with the EU was
within reach and that he had plans to
replace this backstop with an
alternative
while EU officials here in Brussels say
they've never seen any of those plans
that these plans do not exist and that's
why many here think that the real plan
of the Johnson administration is to have
a No Deal brexit so that's what the EU
is preparing for right now expected to
announce new measures to get the
European Union prepared for a No Deal
brexit well Charlotte as you mentioned
Boris Johnson has lost his majority now
in Parliament has a general election in
the UK now become unavoidable well
everything seems to lead up to a general
election that is absolutely right the
question is just how and when is this
going to happen on the how Boris Johnson
has is seeking a general election here
said that but he needs a to search
majority in parliament to see that
through we might see a vote on that
later today and we will have to see if
the Labour Party the opposition party
approves of a general election they have
said they will do so if that bill that I
mentioned before will come through so
this is on the how on the win Boris
Johnson is seeking a general election on
October 15 so that is a date we are
hearing right now that would be shortly
before the big e you summit where brexit
and the deadline and impossible No Deal
brexit is going to be discussed that is
what we are hearing but Parliament is
very afraid that Boris Johnson might
send them mine he has baroque parliament
that Boris Johnson might sent them on
vacation on a break and then push those
general elections back to November first
one day after the UK has left the
European Union possibly if it is after
Boris Johnson's opinion possibly after
that day where the UK has left the
European Union with a No Deal
with a heart brexit so we'll have to see
where this leads today but a general
election does seem very likely and if it
comes to that it will be more of a
referendum again on whether to stay in
the European Union or not a question
that really has divided this country
over the past years max there's a good
chance that the UK will ask the EU for
another extension of the brexit deadline
Willy you grant than that yeah this is
going to be a topic in any case we
expect that at least first of all
because of what's happening in the House
of Commons right now that Boris Johnson
might be forced by Parliament to do that
but even in the case of snap elections
you might have a new government and that
will have a very little time to sort
things out so this is likely to come
many at least here think it's likely to
come but remember what happened in April
back then when they extended the brexit
deadline for the first time it was a
very tough thing to do not because of
Angela Merkel the Chancellor of Germany
she seems more in the camp of we have
this historic responsibility and if we
have more time to sort this out then we
should take it but in my new minima calm
the French president he was very hard to
convince already in April and it'll be
even harder this time around he'll only
do it with a real perspective that
things in the UK actually will change so
the outcome of snap elections might give
him that reasoning might be the thing
that he needs to do that but in any case
the EU automatically granting an
extension not going to happen it'll need
like I said some serious convincing a
lot of uncertainty there DWS max Hoffman
there in Brussels thank you so much and
to Charlotte in London Charlotte Potts
thanks again